but i have heard persistent chatter this
week about the possibility that texans
quarterback deshaun watson will
eventually ask to be traded by the team
one of the huge factors
influencing whether or not that happens
who they hire to be the head coach
they've already said they're going to
involve him in the process well if they
ask him who do you want and they don't
hire that guy there's a potential
reaction so there is talk out there that
the possibility is at least being
broached in conversation with teammates
it's not like he's asked for it it's not
like he ever will
but
this one is fascinating to me
because number one you can't treat a
franchise quarterback like you treat any
other player and say sorry we have a
contract you're bound to be here and
number two at first blush he just signed
a new contract chris there's no way they
can trade him right without taking some
sort of ridiculous 50 million cap hit no
no based upon the signing bonus that was
paid to him which gets spread over a
period of years the capped charge for
trading him would be 21 million and
change
easy for the houston texas
to justify it especially when you
consider the hall that they would get in
return for deshawn watson well yeah that
that's the big thing no i mean listen
this is this would be some story or this
you know bears to be true
uh this would be some big deal because
deshaun watson you know as we've talked
about over the last week and everything
like that is he's phenomenal he is
without a doubt one of the five best
quarterbacks in the game right now so
you know with that the way he plays but
like
uh
mike i i i can't lie when i first heard
of nick caserio you know i love nick
casario and what he does i've worked
with him i've seen him in action i'm a
believer in him but i also did think of
man deshawn watson
just had a uh uh you know a few years
with a guy from new england and it
didn't end that well is he gonna be in
love with you know another new england
try here
and you know all so so that is an
interesting angle just to see where it
goes all together and again listen i i
yeah there's issues within that texans
organization all together that i think
are you know
uh not on the national radar all
you know all together that way so that
would be some big deal for deshawn
watson but something to keep an eye on
and who would want him well
i'd say just about everything but a
handful of teams would at least have to
engage in the analysis the chiefs won't
the seahawks won't uh the bills won't
the packers won't
although no they won't they won't but my
point is you owe it to yourself with a
young ascending talent who has untapped
potential at the quarterback position if
that opportunity presents itself you owe
it to yourself to evaluate where are we
where could we be what would it take and
the other big factor chris is where does
he want to go because if he's going to
push his way out i mean look at it this
way if antonio brown was able to avoid
the bills and engineer a trade to the
raiders well desean watson is only going
to go where deshawn watson wants to go
definitely period right and i think
that's going to be a huge factor in it
as well if it comes to it and again
we're not saying it well but we're
trying to keep you alerted to what could
happen we're very big on trying to stay
ahead of the ball
the hiring of the coach by the houston
texans could be the first domino that
falls in a line that lands with desean
watson playing for someone else yeah i
know you're right and we'll we'll see
where that goes i know now listen if
they hired brian day ball
i would be like oh don't leave man don't
leave this is this offense brian dabo's
offense i know he's from new england and
so is billy o'brien it's not the same
offense
you know billy o'brien's offense is new
england light that's what it is brian
dabal's offense is
you know
i got everything new england and i've
added my own spin and some college stuff
because i was at alabama and i got a lot
of different ways to attack you they got
every play in the history of mankind in
that playbook so i it for from that
purpose i hope deshawn watson doesn't
just take it as weight another new
england guy coming here i don't like
this i want to get out no this is he's
different brian dabo is not your typical
new england guy as in his persona his
personality or the way he coaches
necessarily so uh yeah we'll see and i
mean you're right
everybody's gonna be calling and wanting
to know about desean watson everybody
except the teams you've talked about for
the most part and and
you said it right too you know first off
if a franchise quarterback yeah he just
signed a new country he says he doesn't
want to be there they're going to try to
trade him you don't want your franchise
quarterback to be the leader your team
and not like the place he's at and to
your second point yes he's going to be
able to force where he wants to go if
that does come about because the same
reason nobody's going to want to trade
for a guy that doesn't want to be there
and especially if it's your quarterback
so
this would be an amazing development and
we'll we'll see
and the other thing to keep in mind
unless they do some restructurings and
renegotiations that drive up future cap
numbers and make it more expensive from
a cap standpoint to move on from him it
gets cheaper each year so maybe they
convince him maybe jack eastern throws
an arm around him and sweet talksman
convinces him to give it a year right
with brian dayball or josh mcdaniels or
whoever the coach is if they're not
hiring the guy that desean watson has
recommended and maybe a year from now we
see where it is but but this is
something to monitor sorry texans fans i
know it's been a rough time for you the
past couple of years and
this is what happens when you have a
great player on a dysfunctional team who
looks around and says boy if i was in
kansas city we'd be doing what kansas
city is doing if i was in buffalo we'd
be doing what buffalo is doing how can i
get to a place where i can do what guys
like patrick mahomes and josh allen are
doing
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports